(audience applauding)
- They're still standing.
I'm just saying.
They wanna dance.
- They wanna dance.
- They did. I'm telling
you, dancing feels good.
- Well, I wish there were clubs today.
Remember back in the day.
- It's nice.
- Some serious slow jamming.
- Yeah.
- Y'all work together, right,
on a project?
- Larry Crown.
- You remember Larry Crown?
- Larry Crown. I was like.
- Great movie.
- Larry Crown with Tom Hanks.
- Yeah. That's so awesome.
I was like, I've, y'all
were both coming on.
I feel like I've seen him together.
That's awesome.
Did you like working each other?
Would you be honest?
I'm just kidding.
- Absolutely. Well, I have plans for him.
I have plans.
- What are the plans?
- Him to be in my biopic.
- Oh, yes.
- Play one of my uncles.
- Of course.
- Uncles.
- Okay.
- Unca, U N C A, uncas.
- Uncles. Uncles.
- Okay.
- There were quite a few men in in my life
in my family who protected me.
- Yeah.
- And they were old school.
- Farmers. They wanted the
girls to be self-sufficient.
Drive a car, go fly
fishing, tie the flies.
- Yeah.
- Bring the boat in.
And he and all my uncles would say,
"Baby, I want you and the girls
to do everything the boys can do
so we don't have to worry all the time."
Give them a break.
When they came back from
Vietnam, from the war,
there's nothing harder than
they don't have arms and legs.
But we went fishing.
We took care of the cars.
We filled the cars up with gas.
- Yeah.
- Firewood was chopped.
My family's from the Black
West, Wyoming and Colorado.
And so we, Wyoming.
- I ain't never heard of that.
- Yeah. I gave that
information to Richard Pryor.
- Black people from Wyoming?
- Hey, you saw Blazing Saddles.
- Blazing Saddles.
- I gave that information to Richard Pryor
when he was co-writing with Mel Brooks.
- Are you serious right now?
- Yes, ma'am.
- Very serious.
- I want you to tell that story
because I think this is amazing.
I learned about, because I,
equine therapy is so important
and I've had friends
really benefit from it.
And you did as well as a young kid, right?
- Yes.
- Can you tell that story?
I love this story.
I don't love how it started, obviously.
But I just mean like, you ended up,
was it with your grandfather?
- My grandfather and my grandmother
had the farm in Wyoming.
I was traumatized.
I had a couple of incidences
that were tragedy,
very traumatic.
And my grandfather took me up to the farm
where there's animals, large animals.
And because of the trauma
and I still stutter,
I couldn't speak.
And daddy ran.
My uncle went to the juke
joint and left me in the car.
"Pammy, don't get on the horse.
Don't get near the horse.
Don't get near the bull."
What did Pammy do?
Soon as they turned their
back and walked away,
there was this gigantic
draft horse in the pasture.
And I walked over to
him and I looked at him
and something started happening to me
where I now, this wall of
fear and pain was dissipating.
And I climbed the fence
and I got on top of him and I stroked him.
And I remember he looked
at me with the big eyes
and I could feel his heart beating and
- That connection.
- I pulled up on top of him.
My little legs were
splayed out and my braids.
And he says, "I'm gonna
take you for a little walk."
And every step he made,
you could feel the ground shake.
- Power.
- And it came up through
his legs, through my body.
And I could see a horizon
that was totally different.
No rooftops, no fear, no one coming at me,
no one choking me, strangling me,
fighting me as a little girl.
And he took me for a ride
and all of a sudden I could breathe again.
- It's amazing that connection
with animals. It is.
And clap. That's amazing.
- I started talking.
- And that's what I find amazing.
Your stutter started to dissipate.
- It began, it left.
- It's powerful.
That kind of therapy is powerful.
So we are honoring Dr. King today.
So Pam, when is the first
time you learned about him?
- When my mother fell to her knees.
- Wow.
- Watching him march with other
- That's a powerful memory.
- Yes.
With other men who were knowing
they're gonna take the hit.
And the women who had to take the hit.
Barbara Jordan, Shirley Chisholm,
Gloria Steinem, Bella Abzug.
We had one little black and
white television in our den.
And my mom was watching them march
in front of, in Washington.
She fell to her knees.
- That's powerful for kids.
- And she started crying.
- Yeah.
- And she said they
just, and then she said
but the whites who love
us can't fight for us
because they're considered lovers.
And they will have
their house burned down,
or their church burned down,
or they could be lynched.
And my mom, she was inconsolable
and she said you saw all the people
and the faces and the
hearts beyond the heart.
- Sometimes it's hard to see
the hope through the hate.
There's so much hate that is
involved and so much evil.
I feel like that is a
- It's a mental illness.
You know, hate is a mental illness.
- 100%.
- It's not normal.
- That's a huge problem in our country.
But it's also hard to find hope.
That little light.
- I find, I search all the time.
- I wanna say this to those.
So Cedric, you played Dr.
King's closest friend,
Ralph Abernathy.
- Yeah.
And in a Spike Lee movie.
So did you learn anything about Dr. King
that surprised you that maybe wasn't ever,
isn't showcased on the regular?
- Well, in this movie Son of the South,
I actually had studied to do,
I've been cast for Ralph
Abernathy in Selma, too.
But what I found out the
most is their sense of humor.
What I really loved is
between the two of them,
they were really friends and
they had this buddy energy
that I think that you miss
when someone is such a
great historic figure
is that you always see them as serious.
And what I really loved is
that they were friends and buddies
and had this shorthand with
each other and laughed a lot.
- Yeah.
- And so therefore, it was
that understanding that,
how do you do a work like that
when every day seems so serious?
You have to have some degree of
where life is comfortable
and you and that,
that was his partner.
And I like that.
I love the idea of that.
- Well, it's interesting to me.
- They had each other for that.
- It's interesting to me, too, though.
I find like the most deep people I know
are usually comedians.
Even if it's not their job.
They're just
- Yeah.
- They're the people that
make you laugh so hard.
And they have such a deep understanding,
a deep intelligence for a lot of things.
And it is,
they are the more serious
people in my life, as well.
- Sure.
- But I think you have to find that humor
to have that, if balance existed,
but to have that kind of balance, too.
Because you wanna address things
and you wanna be a part of things,
but at the same time
it can be overwhelming
and it feels so big that
you can't conquer it.
You know?
So you need humor.
I wanna ask you, though,
about The Plot Thickens.
I wanna ask you, it's season four?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Season four.
- Yeah. Season four.
- Do you enjoy looking back?
It's about your life.
Do you enjoy that or is it hard?
- I enjoy it because I learned from it.
I learned from how much
I've learned that's changed.
Because sometimes you'll see a movie
that is made in the fifties
and you'll see the same thing
or same movie, 20, 30, 40 years.
And your thoughts and
ideas may have changed
and you're looking at
it in a different way.
- Yeah.
- How many mistakes can
I, what can I not do?
What? Because I'm now
directing and writing and
- Yeah.
- Producing and
- That's so cool.
- I'm learning from that.
I'm learning from watching
- Yeah.
- Your show with Bernie.
- I support other people's successes
and I learned from them.
And I've learned from being
in comedy, horror, action,
working with Quentin Tarantino,
who's been guiding me
and the studio executives
who have been saying, "You just do it.
We will support you."
Fox is "Go, this is gonna happen.
This is gonna happen."
They're like, "I gotta work now."
But I'm always a student.
I don't know it all.
- I hope that never changes.
- It better not.
Will you, will you correct me?
- No. That's for all of us, though.
I hope that that never changes.
I think that's when you die as an artist,
is when you stop learning.
- B.B. King, he played
until he was 90 something.
- Yeah.
- I hope to be,
Betty White was me and Betty.
You know, 99.
I'm hoping to get to 105, at least.
But it
- I don't mind getting to 105
as long as I can still wipe my behind.
That's my only thing.
I don't wanna go out like I came in.
I don't, I don't really.
- Trust me, it'll be different.
You'll have someone do
it for you, you know.
But there's things that
enable me to be humble.
But things that said,
"Look what you've done."
If you wake up breathing
or have a good day
and I can share that.
But we're all. People say I'm Foxy Brown.
No. All y'all Foxy Browns out there.
Where do you think I get it from?
Don't be blaming me.
Don't be blaming Kelly.
- All right. Let's do a quick commercial.
Pam's podcast is The Plot Thickens.
It's available wherever
you get your podcasts.
And Cedric's show The
Neighborhood airs Mondays on CBS.